depuis que nous travaillons sur ce texte
relatif à l'état d'urgence sanitaire
le sénat dans son entière composition à
délibérer dans des conditions sereines
et dans des conditions je le crois de
conscience et de responsabilité
nous entendons depuis quelques heures
une moindre mesure depuis quelques jours
une sorte de procès en irresponsabilité
à l'encontre du sénat voire en démagogie
alors que nous avons donné je le crois
monsieur le ministre au gouvernement
tous les moyens qui était utile pour
combattre le fléau épidémique
nous étions rendez vous je parle
collectivement le 23 mars dernier nous
le sommes toujours
malgré cela des parlementaires de la
majorité ont tenu des propos à notre
endroit
je parle collectivement une fois de plus
qui ne sont pas acceptables indiquant
que le sénat avait pris le texte dont
vous êtes porteur en otage et que les
français auraient sûrement apprécier
davantage d'esprit de responsabilité
j'ai les sites ou alors en indiquant que
par quelle magie les sénateurs saft il
qu'il sera approprié de mettre fin au
confinement
le 8 décembre ce que nous avons jamais
demandé par ailleurs pourquoi ces forces
et empêcher le gouvernement d'agir
d'autres ont même dit c'est vrai qu'à
lire les apports du sénat où peut se
demander s'ils sont utiles
monsieur le ministre nous sommes ici des
parlementaires élus représentants de
notre terre et de nos territoires et de
la nation nous faisons notre travail
celui que nous incombe la constitution
et que nous encore notre conscience
notre responsabilité de parlementaires
nous sommes peut-être pas d'accord avec
le gouvernement
il ya sans doute des divergences de vues
sur la manière de faire mais nous
exerçons notre liberté notre liberté de
poser des questions et de vouloir dans
cette période difficile
non pas vous empêcher de travailler mais
d'assumer notre responsabilité de
contrôler et nous continuerons de le
faire
encore ce soir d'ailleurs nous demandons
simplement
le sénat et l'ensemble des
parlementaires assis sur ses bancs
soient respectées pour le travail qu'ils
font
[Musique]